Kerry lake is still
doing her thing still lying as much as
possible and uh specifically of course
about the election that occurred in
Arizona where she lost as much as she
doesn't want to believe that she did
indeed lose and so I want to check in on
Kerry Lake what's been going on with her
and it's kind of more of the same except
I think as time goes by
she gets more and more delusional as she
gets further away from any reality in
which she's even on a timeline close to
when that election occurred and her
delusion just increases as the time goes
by so here's her actually getting asked
if she would run against Kirsten Cinema
for Senate yikes I don't love thinking
about that
um
uh possible reality take a look I know
that polling has been done showing that
I would beat Kirsten Cinema and I've had
I'll be honest I've had many many people
reach out to me and and all kinds of
people reach out to me suggesting that I
run for Senate my focus 100 is on my
election lawsuit the people of Arizona
were done wrong their sacred vote was
trampled upon and I am fighting to
restore honest elections in Arizona I
you know I want to be very obvious here
and I'm speaking something very obvious
DC is messed up it's corrupt Arizona is
corrupt and we need good people in the
senate in our governor's office at the
state level and at the federal level to
fight this corruption so I am focused
right now on winning this election and
getting Katie Hobbs thrown out of the
governor's office so
the fact that she's still saying she's
focused on winning an election that
happened in November and the victor of
that election has already taken office
is wild and it's what we saw with Trump
still calling for him to be president
him to be uh you know put into the White
House because of the horrible wrongdoing
and as we'll repeat a million times with
these types of claims you have to have
evidence to make such dangerous
dangerous claims and she doesn't have it
and when she went to court her lawsuit
was thrown out because she didn't
provide the evidence now she's appealing
and appealing but this is the reality
and she just can't accept it and so it's
quite wild to watch I have a few more
moments just to update you on recent
interviews with Carrie Lake kind of uh
a broken record I'll say we will not
accept defeat because we won this race
the people showed
did not put up in massive numbers and
they are so afraid of We the People the
political Elite is so afraid of we the
people that they stole this in broad
daylight they'd sabotaged election day
and if we lay down and let them do this
to us now we will never have a country
so we will not
and luckily we got through the Katie
Hobbs
swearing in without any
devastating event brought on by
supporters of Cary Lake but each time
these claims are perpetuated I get
concerned because we know where these
lies can lead and it really is dangerous
here is another example of her just
making the rounds making the same
dishonest claims if they think they can
steal an election and make this movement
of we the people of Mama bears and Papa
bears who care about their kids of
grandmas and grandpas and students just
go away they've got another thing coming
because we're going to work through the
court system and we will be victorious
we're not letting them
what's interesting is all of those
proclamations we will be Victorious and
we see with individuals like Mike
Lindell always predicting no in two
weeks Trump's going to become president
once again and they never seem to learn
their lesson and by they I mean the
followers of individuals like Kerry Lake
Mike Lindell Trump
who say we're going to be victorious
Carrie Lake's saying I'm definitely
going to end up governor and then when
it keeps not happening why is there no
trust lost
one more thing to show you Republican
Arizona state senator Wendy Rogers I
want to show you how this spreads and
how this is still very much a movement
that's alive that is very concerning
bolstering these claims and pretending
like there's some chance in the world
that Carrie Lake could become governor
um before the end of Katie hobbs's term
Kerry Lake should be our governor she
was elected it was stolen and her case
is on appeal right now it will meet the
appeals court which is a three judge
Court here in a couple of weeks it will
still go beyond that irrespective of
that outcome to the Arizona Supreme
Court where we hope for a final uh
justifiable resolution of this situation
we already have a resolution Katie Hobbs
was one
now she's the governor
um that is the resolution so one of the
things I talk about a lot is when
answering the question of why is it
important to talk about individuals like
Carrie Lake she's not in power neither
is Trump but why should we still discuss
them
the reason is while the Maga ideology
lost I would say in the midterms and the
American people generally were against
it it still is very much prominent
within our current political reality and
holds a lot of people within that uh you
know ideology and so to understand the
movement to address and confront the
movement we have to check in with and uh
look at the lies being told by the
leaders such as Carrie Lake who commands
that movement and it is very dangerous
stuff going on as you saw there if you
like what you're seeing and you're
watching this on YouTube or listening to
the podcast or wherever you are
consuming this content and you want to
check out my show you can go to Luke
Beasley on YouTube there should be a
link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube quick break we'll be
right back